pour tous les jardiniers amateurs cette
visite guidée à toulouse à travers les
serres municipales de la ville ouverte
exceptionnellement public à rendez-vous
qui suscite un véritable engouement
on attend plus de vingt mille personnes
ce week end isabelle de liant david bres
il faut longer le canal du midi pour
découvrir les jardiniers de toulouse et
leurs serres où naissent chaque année
plus de 450 mille plants destinés à
fleurir la ville offerts à la curiosité
du public
ce travail séduit les grands et les
petits c'est vrai que ça donne envie de
me mettre un peu les mains dans la terre
et de voir ce que ça va
sam hamad est planté et on avait oublié
les arrose lcf année elle n'avait qu'une
seule qui avait rester c'est un haricot
ici on joue à se perdre dans des
labyrinthes verts on s'enivre des
parfums d'une glycine centenaire comparé
à la recherche des violettes
emblématique de toulouse et surtout on
fait le plein de conseils pour son
jardin
nous avons un gain villiers qui ne
flancheraient pas et j'ai demandé
pourquoi l'art iso bon j'ai reçu la
réponse j'ai licencié il ya le plaisir
des yeux ya l'odorat mais il ya surtout
l'aspect culturel que je suis en train
de découvrir que je trouve très
important
passionnant jaune ou bleu des étendards
point ce attire le regard des pièges à
insectes témoin d'une protection
biologique des plantes
on utilise d'autres insectes qui vont ou
parasites et les insectes nuisibles ou
le manger c'est le moment ou jamais de
s'occuper de son jardin et les petits
visiteurs repartent avec une plantules
d'oeillets d'inde
c'est vrai qu'on essaie de faire évoluer
la palette chaque année en introduisant
de nouvelles plantes 1
donc bon c'est vrai que ont réintroduit
les légumes d'aller dans les massifs
mais les fenouils les cards etc qui sont
intéressants aux décorations par le
feuillage actuellement les pavots
inspire beaucoup les jardiniers on
repart d'ici la main verte